oh god what am I looking at here uh uh
its undulating why is it undulating oh
oh I thought that was something else
that is a lovely looking [ __ ] chicken oh
that's cool
now when do they start [ __ ] get fat
and poop get fat and poop get fat and
poop was I really started at the top of
that mountain because if so holy damn I
went far down just like my career and
through the power of magic and belief I
have caused the car to float on
nothingness aren't I just the greatest
driver that ever was were like oh yeah
that's the stuff
oh yeah can I jump off I sure can well
at least I got the rooster he's the one
with the penis he can really do damage
on this one oh oh oh God chainsaw Oh Oh
God sounds great dad what damaging his
gear
realism we're all doomed
it's a sperm-ship mark I love you so oh
my god your butt is on fire oh sorry I
hope this is your balls rubber floor
blur blur blur blur blur blur goddamn
blorph blarp blarp Worf I'm the poop
master I'm the poop extraordinaire I am
the God of all poop
I am the the CEO of poop incorporated I
am the man these titles just aren't
getting any better as I go along
Thank You tiny tortoise Tim you know
you'll always be my little biscuit oh
that sounds familiar
I wonder 100 you know places and things
Oh sounds like you're making excuses and
trying to buy time cuz your brain can't
keep up with the [ __ ] that your ass is
cashing for you what the hell did you
say tiny turtle report it's them oh well
this this is awkward well oh okay all
right chica you peed on the floor so you
get to wear the Fedora of shame you wear
it at you wear it where the Fedora you
chewed up you wear it are you proud of
what you've done
are you proud - top of the morning to
you laddies
that's not okay that's not okay don't
worry I'll be here watching waiting
there okay thanks Bernie oh that's what
you get for listening to music that's
one my way there's some avant-garde to
him let me see if I can do it
okay okay ready thanks for watching all
of the videos in this compilation are
available in the description so check
them out and if you'd like to see more
in the future please leave a like to let
me know if you enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see more than a daily
basis please subscribe today or if
you're already subscribed share this
video with a friend thanks again for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video bye bye